i mean the crown broke but it's amazing
tell me about the outfit tonight hood by
air
a crown that was made for me 10 years
ago and i dug it up just to make a
statement and then of course it broke
but i'm holding it with my
with my finger
i think that is a perfect metaphor for
your incredible career everybody is so
excited for this documentary what can
they expect um
[Music]
great art
[Music]
thoughtfulness
incredible dancing incredible music
uh
gosh
provocation politics spirituality
family everything well your kids are in
it and you're throwing it my boyfriend's
in it everybody's in it your daughter's
been it's just at the met gal she's
modeling for rihanna she's in the
documentary how proud are you and where
do you see her going from here i mean i
think anything's possible for her she's
way more talented than i am than i was
am whatever so i'm really proud of her
well we know you're an incredible mother
thank you um you are such a warrior you
you speak up for so many people one
person has been britney spears over and
over again have you talked yeah yeah i
just spoke to her today actually really
yeah what did you guys talk about and
what's your message just hey how are you
girl what's up
just checking in on her and
congratulating on her on her marriage
yeah i've been supporting pending
marriage yeah of course yeah i love her
well let's go do some photos real quick
what's next for you and the fans want to
know could we ever see you do a vegas
residency that's a question we get a lot
on our social media no um but i am
making a movie about my life so who's
gonna be in it i don't know okay
[Music]
you